let's continue our conversation about
dns and start talking about dns cache
poisoning attacks right very cool name
very cool kind of attack
so dns is the system we use to
link domain names like google.com to an
ip address
which might be changing you know day to
day and that allows us to type in
convenient human readable
urls into bars and actually get a
website back from a computer that exists
which is useful dns cache poisoning is
is a is essentially a flaw in dns
where we can inject or an attacker could
inject
a malicious ip address into
a name server so that it tells people to
go to this ip address instead of the
actual ip address right
now it's less common now it was quite a
big deal when when these these attacks
first started appearing
we already talked about dns let's talk
very briefly you've got a computer here
and you use
some process which wants to visit a
website or ping
some machine you need to look up that ip
address
right so what you're going to do is
you're going to look up
your name server of choice right
probably your isps one or something like
that and you're going to put in a query
here now this is a recursive resolver
it's probably not going to know
it will check its cash this is its cash
right you will also have a cash by the
way which for the sake of argument we
don't have anything in it
it will then send off to here which will
go to a route
and then it will go to a you know a
global top level domain and so on dot
dot until it gets to what we call an
authoritative name server
for that zone right and then it will
give us an actual ip address now this
will take some amount of time because
there's a few hops here
root and then back and then you know and
so because these won't generally
speaking forward on our request for us
they're not that they don't work that
hard for on our behalf so
there's some amount of time passes when
this name server
reaches out for an answer where we have
an opportunity to give it an answer
that it wasn't expecting right which
sounds way more exciting than perhaps it
is one thing we talked about was this
will put a query id of let's say
1000 on this query which will actually
eventually go to this name server here
now while it's going out with a query id
we have an opportunity to send back a
response with a query id of a thousand
that points to a different machine so
let's imagine this
is my nefarious server here all right so
this is sort of my skull and crossbones
thing it's the worst thing i've ever
seen i've got to try and fix
how do you make it look like ah i i know
what it is there we go that's
is that bit better okay this is my very
nefarious server
and you know who knows what's on there
like malware and stuff um
but what i want to do is this has got a
different ip so let's say for the sake
of
ease it's 10.00.9.9
and what's going to happen is this will
come up here and then my attacking
machine
will send a stream of responses
to this with query id 1000 query idea
thousand and one
query idea thousand and two we do a
thousand and three
and so on is it just chancing its arm
it's just having a go yeah and we'll
talk about how you choose a query id in
a minute but yes
basically it's just sending a sequence
of query ids
and with this name server it's basically
saying
so let's suppose this query was for
google.com this query is also going to
be what is google.com
and we're saying google.com is 10.0.9.9
which it isn't
right it's my virus server all that has
to happen for this to work
right is for this query id to be correct
and for this to be received before the
actual authoritative answer comes back
from a google name server right
which given that this is probably
somewhere else in the world you've got
a few couple hundred milliseconds maybe
if i'm on a similar network to this
machine that could be a big problem
to this machine so how do we guess this
query id
well the good news was that you know
back in sort of the early 2000s
they just incremented a counter every
time so if they sent a query id 1001
you there was there was good money it
was going to be a thousand and two the
next one and a thousand and three and so
on
so all you need to do is observe a query
id
and then spam it when the next one's up
right so what you would do
is you would send a request to this name
server for some unknown domain
right which points back to your name
server
and then see what query id it used right
so you have a way of sniffing out what
the query idea was
and then all you would do is spam let's
say 20 or 30 of the nearest numbers to
it
and you'd probably hit right and then it
gets worse right because
not only has this now received the wrong
answer but it's also cached it
right so you say vip for google.com
is this right and also this is going to
be valid
for 20 days this is called the time to
live now
if you said that then this is gonna not
bother you know asking
actual google again for 20 days right
and so what will happen is
so someone else on this website goes
someone else here
goes to google.com they get a response
that's this ip which is incorrect
and they will get that same response
while that remains in the cache right
which could be for a long long time
that is a huge problem if you go to a
website
you know you don't see the ip address
right on your browser for example you
just type in
you know amazon credit uk nottingham.edu
at uk
you just you know youtube.com you type
them in the domain name
could be anything right there are other
checks and balances like certificates
that we can talk about that will prevent
this from causing a huge problem but
back when this was a problem that also
wasn't as robust
and that nefarious server is it likely
that it's going to serve up something
that looks close enough to the real
thing
i mean that depends on what the attacker
wants to do right but that's one option
well what you could do is you could have
a fake logon prompt
which looks exactly like the front page
of some known social network or
something like that
and then you just bag the credentials
rather than um
you know logging them in because you
can't right and then you would forward
them
to the actual website and they just
assume that nothing happened they go
that's strange and log in again and it
would work the second time because
they've been
re-routed or you know modern day you
just serve them an exploit kit right
which is essentially a
web server that stuffs them full of
malware
as quickly as possible it looks at what
browser they're running what flat what
you know adobe
flash plugins they're running what
javascript um and java
runtimes are running and tries to hit
them with the correct targeted payloads
right which will join them into a botnet
or serve them ransomware or something
along these lines
you don't really want this to happen to
you there's a way of flushing out that
cash
i mean this could be done by by an
administrator but they're not going to
because no one's no one's looking at
these caches right and then nobody kind
of knows this has happened no no
no unless you notice it's like an affair
for this website or there's a
certificate issue which is
you know likely these days for for the
web certainly for other services not
running on
you know using tls then maybe not
there's really no way to know
until this expires that's a huge problem
now they did start to mitigate this
right um because it gets a little bit
more complicated you see
so it was spot it was spotted that
incrementing this
query number was a bad idea right so
what they would do instead
is they would randomize it right now
it's 16 bits so you've got 2 to the 16
you've got about 65 000 different
query ids that you could do right now
you've got your chance of hitting this
is much much lower
then comes along dan kaminski in about
2008 right who's a security researcher
and he comes up with this idea
that allows you to get around this issue
so what he does is instead of requesting
google.com
or facebook.com he requests you know
random one two three dot
and then random1235.google now those are
kind of similar addresses
but they're new each time so this name
server doesn't have them in the cache
and so it performs with lookup right and
it gives you another opportunity to
guess like say 50 random numbers
before the actual response comes back
and then you can try again
and then you can try again and you can
do the attack in about 10 seconds now
the neat thing about this
because of course overriding someone's
random random1234.google.com is only
useful if they go
to that website the interesting thing
about this that was you know really
quite good
was that what dan also did was he
attaches to the response
oh and by the way i don't know for this
one
but the authoritative name server for
google.com is actually this ip
and points the actual name server at
the attacker's name server right neat so
so what happens basically is the name
server gets a response
a spammed response back but says i don't
know but this one this guy might
but don't trust him because he's he's
he's shady
so um so you have to set up your own
name server
but then all bets are off right once you
control a name
server for some zone like google or
facebook or amazon or something like
that
you can then serve whatever ip you want
for any query that comes in to that one
right
that's a big big problem so the final
change that they made and this was about
in response to this was and i should add
by the way that there was a single
um i believe there was a single domain
name client that already did this
which was dan bernstein's right all the
others followed suit
they don't just randomize the query id
they also randomize the source port from
which the query
originates so you go if you remember
from networking
you go from an ip to an ip but you also
go from a source port to a destination
port right that's in tcp or udp
and if you randomize that
you've then got 16 2 16
possible queries and 2 to 16 ish a
little bit less
possible ports right then you've got
somewhere
you know but technically speaking about
4 billion different possible
combinations
some of the ports are not going to be in
use so
maybe hundreds of millions of different
combinations this becomes much much more
difficult much much
slower this is not so practical right
technically it's still possible
right they haven't solved the issue what
they've done is made it harder
you know who when someone comes along
with enough bandwidth to do this
maybe they will be able to pull it off
the long-term solution to something like
this
it's probably not random port numbers
and things it's probably dns sec
which is where you actually um
authenticate things like the losing
global top level domains and some of
these name servers using certificates
right and public key infrastructure and
that means that it's much much harder
to set up a spoof name server because
the dns resolver will check the
certificate and realize
it's bogus i'm not going to use this
query at all
um so this actually already exists in a
lot of the higher level domains
some of it lots of name servers still
don't support this but it is being
rolled out so that's you know a good
thing
you only have to work out whether it's
worth alerting the user
if you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key you
perform the encryption
you generate the potential rpis and you
compare them with the ones you've seen
or if you want a more slightly
comprehensible message it's saying maybe
you haven't applied a function to
enough arguments